one of the nice things about putting
liquid out for academic use is we've
spent a lot of time making it as easy as
possible for you to use it for you to
download it install it and learn it with
a minimum amount of work to make sure
you're up and running as quickly as
possible to this end the getting started
page on this website tells you exactly
all the steps you need to do for Windows
OSX or Linux to be up and running today
the system uses a compiler in the case
of Windows it's Visual Studio and the F
sharp compiler and equivalent tools are
available on OSX and Linux namely
xamarin and monodevelop
all of these are freely available you
can download install and be up and
running very quickly liquid itself is
just a zip file you download it you
unpack it and you're done
there's no installation there's no place
you have to go to register there's no
mail you have to send or keys we've just
made it as easy as possible all you need
to do the first time you run it it will
ask you to do a license acceptance you
type ally and you're up and running
that's it plain and simple the other
thing that's really nice is we made sure
there was a lot of help we have a
hundred page user's manual with
annotated examples all those examples
are in a samples directory with how to
run those samples and how to interact
with them there's also on this website a
video tutorial that's 45 minutes that
takes you end-to-end how to install how
to run and how to write your own quantum
algorithms actually runs through a
complete example end to end
there's also over 700 pages of HTML
documentation for the API so those of
you that are programmers and want to get
into the details it's all there and it's
all available if it isn't obvious or
they're things that aren't well
explained we have a community we're
building around this github site you can
post questions problems and get back to
us as well as two other members of the
community and find out if it's been
solved and what you need there's also a
mailing list which is referenced here
that you can go to the mailing list and
send us direct questions and we'll be
happy to respond back we're looking to
get as many people as possible to use
the simulator quantum computing is at
its beginnings there's only about four
basic algorithms that are fundamental to
quantum computing that's not enough to
build all of this on top of if you think
about the early days of digital
computers it was a lot of years of
development of very fundamental
algorithms there are still new
algorithms for sort coming out sixty
years later we need the same sort of
things to start happening in quantum
computers so in the next 10 to 20 years
when the actual hardware shows up we
have something to run on them the
samples include quantum chemistry Shor's
algorithm all sorts of things that we
talked about in our papers and that are
again documented across all of the help
so we look forward to you downloading
liquid and trying it for yourself you
should be able to kick the tires with a
little bit of effort maybe half hour
total and see if you like the whole idea
of quantum computing the F sharp
compiler which you may not be familiar
with is very easy to learn if you know
Java or Python or any block structured
programming language you'll be able to
pick it up almost immediately and we
look forward to hearing from you on the
website and on the mailing list